this is a great fight because this fight
ali was um
he was a young man and believe it or not
before ali came on the scene this guy
was a monster this guy was um
this guy was a oh man he was a
juggernaut um
guys um he didn't even have to hit the
guy only they had to do to walk in a
circle around him till they dropped dead
of a heart attack
and um he was just a mean
listen this is a bad man this man right
here is really a bad man inside the ring
and out
this guy terrorizes cities by himself
um he goes man police start police try
to
um question him he knocks them out he
breaks their jaw um he puts them in coma
this is the man you this this is guy
that you only
you read about and and fables and stuff
this is a real bad man right here
inside the ring and out and because
muhammad ali
um you know you have to only talk to
guys
within this era and know about fighting
aliyah so
he has superseded this guy so bad that
people forgot about him but before ali
came on the scene this guy
did um man he made boxing looked so easy
he made it look very easy this is the
mike tyson of the
of the 60s and late 50s right here
you can never you know only a reason why
ali beat these guys because ollie
believe it or not
i was wondering what did he have that
ali had the will to win like nobody ever
lived in boxing
he had the what the will of the wind
he's um we look at ali and
when when you think about it right you
see this guy ali ali is um
in all actuality um he really passes
more as a male model than he is the
fighter
when you think about it um no really
really if you just look at ali he's more
of a male model than he is a fighter
but he's a ferocious animal he's almost
like um
he's like a ferocious savage
saber-toothed tiger with a very
pretty face and um that's what we don't
see
that's what we just don't see that in
these kind of people and that's what he
was he was just
you man he had his pain threshold was
just out of this world
and he was just um the quintessential is
a prototype of the great fighter
and he did everything wrong you know he
pulled back he never punched to the body
you know and he just um he walked me
down explained this to me
never do a body punch in his career okay
so you you know me
i don't know what you mean he never hit
anybody in a chat in their career i
i i was
i was exactly home okay okay
never punched through the body hit
anybody in the in his whole career to
the body and not only just some
hebrews believed ali believed that he
was truly a guard and nobody on this
planet could be them and how dare you
even think that you could beat me
so he came on with him everything that
he believed he projected to his opponent
you know um now how to look when you
really look at how did valley beat
george foreman
huh how does ali be sunny listen how did
you beat these guys how did he even be
joe frazier fighting the way he fights
he beats him because he refused to lose
you know i mean he was just a remarkable
human being
and and this is uh i mean in in some way
you and ali have something in common
there through customato because
customato also taught you
this will to destroy
and to win at any cost well ali wasn't a
destroyer i leave with um
more of a manipulator he made you
believe that you couldn't beat him
how did he do that because he told you
you couldn't
he made you believe you know you look at
this guy you see these big monsters they
landed these heavy punches on this guy
and they fight in the back and i'll even
hit you you hit ali with a
you know you hit him with um this
building and he said that's all you have
your sister hits harder than that and he
just he talks really bad about you
in the clinches ali i'll leave you with
things that i'm
not really permitted to say in the
audience he would really talk bad about
you in the clinches
and um it's okay you can no i prefer not
to um
he's just a remarkable man and i don't
think we ever see a man like him again
and um he's just incredible
but when you when you say he spoke
he did it while he was fighting oh
absolutely but it was
more than what he told us what he
believed and what he um accomplished and
how he beat the guy
he he beat you with his punches but um
he's just um
we're never gonna see a man like him
again not in the ring no
never